hello everyone and welcome to bloodline
the taxonomy of fear where we examine
what if anything makes a movie scary and
this week we are going to examine the
subgenre of home invasion horror through
the lens of the movie cherry tree lane
which is uk import and we start the
movie with a family just tucking in to
dinner husband and wife sit down with
some unexpected visitors coming knocking
and it turns out their son seb who's at
soccer practice he's been a snitching
and if there's one thing we've learned
from movies about the criminal
underworld nobody likes to submit yep
one thing you do not do
so what defines home invasion horror
jordan
well the home is the sanctuary and i
think that's the first and foremost
point here you establish the home like
they do at the beginning of this movie
as a place where you do banal mundane
things when you're just letting your
hair down crying bacon in the nude
exactly exactly maybe just things like
that well in a home invasion horror
movie that safety is breached by the
people who've come into your ultimate
safe space and taken it over and sort of
made it their domain number two the
number of perpetrators is generally
equal to the number of victims so
there's an evened out balance of power
which eventually switches well it leans
towards the the perpetrators but then
that switches at some point in the movie
and in this movie that switch happens
way late yeah
it happened a little too far towards the
end there was too much a little bit too
much torment happening before the switch
happened it wasn't for weed i'll be
popping myself
it's about the one thing that keeps me
calm
and on the note of torment there's a
prolonged period in these movies of a
lot of psychological torture even if
you're not directly interfaced with your
assailants as they are in this movie
you're aware of them the entire time in
the enclosed space of your home
sanctuary and all those elements sort of
come together to rack the brain of the
person who's being victimized
hours of sleep lost how many hours did
you lose jordan well with this
particular movie i'd say the hours of
sleep lost were the hours i spent
venting about it afterwards to my friend
who i watched it with because i felt
completely left flat by this movie it
was it had so many tools to succeed it
had very good performances from the
actors i thought it had a nice use of
lack of soundtrack to establish like
tension in this empty audible space i
thought the motivation for the people
invading was decent enough but i i don't
think it capitalized on any of those
tools i was so
incredibly hollow until the last five
minutes when i had an emotional eruption
at the events on screen but until then i
was just completely disengaged from
really the people who were being
victimized and i was not in any way
afraid of the people doing the
victimizing wow really i had a
completely different reaction i lost
about three hours of sleep because
probably because the the perpetrators in
this movie were young and they were
disorganized and therefore more
unpredictable kind of like a baby
rattlesnakes are more dangerous than
full-grown rattlesnakes because they
can't control their venom sure and i
think the ambiguous ending was what
troubled me the most because the father
is left with this key decision and it
ends right there and i felt like the
director was asking us what we would do
in that situation and what i and i
realized what i would do was totally not
pretty and i thought that was a nice use
of device like that was another one of
those tools where it could have been so
right and i the the last few minutes of
the movie were really satisfying for me
in in several ways but until that moment
in time it was just like i mean i might
as well have been frying bacon in the
nude
like it would have been more both of us
brian bacon in the news
all right jay you've ended up in the
perilous situation of home invasion
what have you learned from cherry tree
lane number one a butter knife is used
for spreading butter a steak knife is
used for cutting through duct tape yeah
getting the job done and if you want to
decorate your home in a functional
manner maybe adorn your living space
with large blunt instruments to take the
place of the weapon that you don't have
like for example i don't know a three
and a half foot tall candelabra that you
found in the attic where can we get one
of those gosh i don't know
and number three keep your emergency
calls short and concise particularly if
someone's exsanguinating upstairs this
is the time when you pull out your inner
american and stop being so british
enough with the oh please do you know
when you you might be arriving do you
think do you have an estimated time of
your oh thank you so much at that point
in the movie i would have been all
american i would be like get here now
click oh yeah victim on my rampage that
operator
all right your video pick of the week
jay i'm going to recommend but not
recommend michael hannicki's funny games
this movie is only for the hard core
horror fan because it wrecked me for
weeks i totally do not recommend it
i rescind that recommendation and i'm
gonna go with another movie from 2007 a
french film called inside directed by
alexandre bustillo and julian marie and
it is part of what is called the new
french extremity of movies and this
stuff gets pretty grisly a pregnant
woman is trapped in her home and being
attacked by a woman who wants that baby
inside her one way or another those
french are tris crazy super
savage that's it for this episode of
bloodline email us at bloodline
wired.com we'd like to hear from you and
as we'd like to say here at bloodline
it's just a movie jordan god really i
mean really bad
you